in the latest step towards a concession
president trump has said he will
leave the white house if the electoral
college voted for joe biden
he was answering a question during his
annual thanksgiving call
to the u.s military i i it's going to be
a very hard
thing to concede because we know there
was massive fraud
i'm going to go with another question go
ahead so if if the electoral college
does elect president-elect joe biden are
you not going to leave this building
just so you certainly will certainly i
will
and you know that
well let's speak to our correspondent in
washington helen ann smith he's
nudging towards a concession there
reluctantly by the sound of it hello man
yeah it's just the latest in a series of
hints that the president might be
accepting the reality of the situation
as you say nudging towards
that concession but with none of the
typical hallmarks that we might expect
of a concession this
event was just uh so symptomatic if you
like some of the contradictions we've
heard from the president throughout this
week
uh to one question asked whether he
would leave the white house
on january the 20th when biden is
inaugurated he said of course i will
but just a few answers apart from that
uh one of the other reporters asked him
uh if he had any plans for his last
thanksgiving in the white house at
thanksgiving today in the us
um and he railed in response to that
question
uh talking about a rigged election
talking about it being stolen from him
i think it is part of a developing
picture that we're seeing from the
president i think
from his actions and from his words he
does understand
the reality of the situation he knows
he'll be leaving the white house he's
done things such as
approve the beginning of the transition
process here in washington this week
he's done things like
start to pardon some of his political
allies normally an act of an outgoing
president
so i think he does accept the reality
but i don't think we will ever
necessarily hear that formal concession
from him because
this narrative that the election was
somehow stolen from him that there was
fraud
that it was rigged it's likely that he
will continue to use this platform
uh for whatever he does next be that
potentially a 2024
re-election bid or indeed something else
many thousands of americans still
passionately support and believe him
and it's perhaps for them that he will
continue to remain this narrative in
public
that there was fraud going on but i
think it's looking increasingly likely
now that come january the 20th
he will leave the white house uh albeit
perhaps not quietly
and planning a big rally in georgia on
saturday he said campaigning for the
republican senators there hello nan
thank you